Why should you watch One Piece? Where do I
even start! Maybe you just keep stumbling
across this anime and finally have given in to
find out what all the hype is about. With only
a few years to go left in the series,
and the beginnign of the final saga,
now’s the perfect time to come aboard the Straw
Hat’s ship and sail to the One Piece along with
the rest of the fandom. Or you might already
be a full-on believer and know how absolutely,
earth-shatteringly brilliant this piece of
fiction is and we just can’t help but want
everyone you know to experience it, too. Like
me for my mate Daidus, who asked me for a video
on why he should start One Piece. Here is the
super short, really not long at all answer.
Chapter 1: A brief history of One PIece
I don’t know if you’ve ever tried to convince
someone to take the plunge and read the series,
but it can be a hard sell. Watching a 26
episode series can be enough of a commitment,
but asking someone to read 1,000 chapters? It
can seem downright daunting. Not to mention,
maybe some people are turned off by the cartoonish
art style, thinking it’s not as serious or cool as
some of their other favorite series. Well,
I’m here to change your mind abou that.
Thanks to a…questionable… 4Kids dub, and a
few other factors, One Piece has had a hard
time growing its fanbase in the West compared to
series like Dragon Ball or Naruto, but let’s look
at the facts: This is the most successful manga
of all time. One Piece has outsold every other
comic series but Superman. Its sales numbers
have beaten out both Spiderman and Batman,
whose publication histories predate One Piece
by decades. Estimated sales placed Eiichiro Oda
within the top 10 best selling authors of all
time. He’s just passed Dr. Seuss and soon One
Piece will even outsell Harry Potter. Simply put,
One Piece, with a serialization spanning 25 years,
is a worldwide sales juggernaut.
Why? Because it’s just that good.
Before we get started, though, you might
want to know some of the basics - so what’s
One Piece about? One Piece takes place 20 years
after the execution of the King of the Pirates,
Gol D. Roger. On the executioner’s stand, Roger
announced to the world that he left his treasure,
the One Piece, hidden somewhere out in the
world’s most dangerous sea, the Grand Line,
a terrifying strip of ocean that spans
the globe. The announcement of this great
treasure lead to a great age of piracy, which
brings us to our protagonist, Monkey D. Luffy,
a rambunctious young pirate who has rubber powers
thanks to eating a devil fruit - a magical fruit
that bestows special abilities to someone who
eats them, but renders them unable to swim (a
pretty big drawback in a story that takes place
on the high seas). Throughout Luffy’s adventure,
he gathers together a crew who fight by
his side as he takes on rival pirates
and the world government in an attempt
to find the world’s greatest treasure.
There are four qualities that make One Piece
stand out among its peers: The world building,
the plot, the characters, and the tone. Are
there more qualities than just these that
make One Piece fantastic? Of course, but we don’t
want to go into any dangerous spoiler territory
and dampen your experience of the series. So
without further ado, let’s get into chapter 2:
Teh World Of One PIece
If you ask the average fan what their favorite
thing about One Piece is, a lot of them will
say its outstanding world building. If
all you’ve seen is promotional images,
it probably seems like One Piece is just a nice
little story where our crew sails around getting
into hijinx. What I definitely wasn’t ready for
when I started the series was a complex web of
political intrigue that easily stands on the level
of a series like Game of Thrones or Lord of the
Rings. If you enjoy fleshed out fantasy worlds,
you’ll fall in love with the world of One Piece.
This world is filled with pirates searching for
the ultimate treasure, the One Piece, but along
the way our crew visits several islands, each with
its own unique government, culture, creatures,
etc. One island may be filled with prehistoric
dinosaurs and battling giants, whereas the next
is an expansive desert kingdom. One island may
be based on feudal Japan and the other might be
a dream-fueled candyland straight out of a Disney
movie. And the wild thing is that all of these
diverse places form a cohesive whole. We don’t
simply stop off and then sail away into the
horizon, never to think about those past islands
again. Instead, they all interact seamlessly with
one another. Each kingdom or island the Straw
Hats visit are connected politically through
the World Government, a shadowy organization
that claims to uphold the peace and defend
people from evil pirates, but in reality causes
just as much suffering as those pirates do.
The world of One Piece is composed of many
factions that move independently from our
main characters. And while Straw Hat Luffy
certainly makes his mark on the world, he’s
just one small fish in a very big pond. While the
story sagas are shaped by the Straw Hats’ actions,
the world is always moving and shifting behind
the scenes as well. Between each major story arc,
Oda shows us what the major players of the world
are up to elsewhere. In no other series will you
see a fanbase get so ecstatic about something as
seemingly simple as a newspaper, but when Big News
Morgans drops the latest issue you better believe
we’re about to get some mind-blowing updates.
Simply put, this world doesn’t seem like a game
board for pieces to move around on. It feels like
a real living, breathing place and we care deeply
about its many inhabitants. Oda has filled each of
these islands with so much care and consideration
that we’re on the edge of our seats while we
wait to see how the complex political dynamics
play out. And that is all thanks to chapter 3:
The Characters
And we have to talk about the stars of
the show, the incredible characters,
and wow does One Piece have some fantastic ones.
I mean, with over 1,000 characters in the series,
there’s a little something for everyone here,
but central to One Piece is the Straw Hat Crew.
Our main character, Monkey D. Luffy, is unlike
any other shonen protagonist. On the surface,
he seems to share some traits with other heroes.
He’s got the brains - or lack thereof - of Goku,
and a lofty goal like Naruto, but no one has the
conviction that Luffy does. And while he wouldn’t
do too well on his standardized tests, he has an
intuitive emotional intelligence that allows him
to make friends everywhere he goes. More than
his rubber body, his true power is the way that
he relates to others and fights for those he
cares about. Most of the time he’s carefree,
silly even, but when it’s time to get serious,
he’ll send a chill up your spine and you’ll be
cheering for him when he gives villains what
they deserve (usually a really big punch).
The rest of the crew is also fantastic.
The absolute badass swordsman, Zoro;
the greedy navigator, Nami; the cowardly
sniper, Usopp; the suave chef, Sanji;
the cotton-candy loving reindeer doctor, Chopper,
and a singing skeleton named Brook. As well as
some others that I won’t spoil for now because
their joining can come as a bit of a surprise.
Every one of these characters not only has
spectacular feats, but they have dreams and
convictions that match their captain’s dream to
become the pirate king. And while they’re fun and
even silly on the surface, they all have depth.
As we learn about the tragedies they suffered in
childhood that made them who they are today, we
fall in love with this cast of characters. Also
you will definitely 100% cry when you get to
their backstories…so just be ready for that.
Of course, our main crew are only the beginning.
The Straw Hats also encounter many others on
their travels and some standouts are the
amazing villains. The Marines are tasked
by the World Government to hunt down the
lawbreaking pirates, which means our main
cast are on the run from fearsome members like
Captain Smoker or Admiral Akainu. However,
there are also oopposing pirates such
as the Seven Warlords of the Sea,
which includes fierce and intimidating characters
like the criminal mastermind, Sir Crocodile,
or the greatest swordsman in the world, Hawkeyes
Mihawk. When we’re introduced to these characters,
they are insurmountable obstacles - some
of them are literally impossible to even
touch. It makes it all the more satisfying when
Luffy and his crew use their resolve to overcome
these villains and save the innocent
people on the islands they encounter.
And speaking of those innocent people, the Straw
Hats have their fair share of allies on the seas
of the Grand Line, too. Some are royalty
who rule the various islands they visit,
such as Nefertari Vivi, the princess of
Alabasta, but some are even fellow pirates,
like the fan favorite Trafalgar Law.
And then there are the legends who either
in the past or present have shaped the One
Piece world itself: People like Gol D. Roger,
the pirate who on the execution stand, started
the great age of piracy by telling people across
the world to search for his treasure, the One
Piece. Throughout the adventure of One Piece,
you’ll meet a fascinating cast of characters. And
if it sounds like a lot, well, no worries there,
Oda takes his time in each location to
let us get to know these characters and
to fully develop them. It’s one of
the reasons that One Piece’s length
works in its favor - it’s all killer,
no filler. Which brings me to chapter 4:
The Plot
The plot of One Piece is another fantastic
reason you should read this series. The
amazing thing about One Piece isn’t that
it has over 1,000 chapters. It’s that it
has 1,000 chapters and it’s still going
strong - the arcs being published right
now are some of the best One Piece has to offer.
There’s a simple reason for this - The mangaka,
Eiichiro Oda, planned his story from
the beginning. I know that seems simple,
but you’d be amazed how many authors don’t
know how their story will end when they begin
publication - they just kind of start from
a premise and make it up as they go along.
25 years ago, Luffy set out to find the ultimate
treasure - the One Piece. He’s still searching
for that treasure. And many are skeptical that
whatever’s revealed will be disappointing - like
the treasure will be “the friends they made along
the way.” However, Oda has gone on record saying
that the treasure is something physical. He’s
had the final panel and the overall story of
the series planned for decades. And while
he does insert fun details and ideas along
the way to expand on the world he’s created, the
broad strokes of the story are well thought out.
It would have been one thing to have
a great idea for a pirate adventure
and just letting Luffy start his journey
without having the end in mind. Eventually,
he may have run out of ideas. But ever since
the beginning, Oda has been constructing a story
with this singular goal. Which, honestly, makes
it an impressive series not just among manga,
but among literature in general.
One way we see this is with Oda’s
masterful hints and foreshadowing. Characters
will be mentioned in the early beginnings of the
story only to show up and play a larger role
hundreds of chapters later. It just goes to
show the thoughtful planning that went into
creating this masterfully structured story.
Not to take digs too hard at other series, but
many of them seem to be developed based on a
central, interesting premise, but eventually
fall apart because the storytellers didn’t
begin with the ending in mind. We’ll call it
the J.J. Abrams effect. To leave the world
of anime momentarily, we can think about how
TV shows like LOST or the much maligned Star
Wars Sequel Trilogy begin by Abrams setting up
many mysteries, so fans get sucked in by the
intrigue. The problem is that Abrams has not
figured out what the solution to the mystery
is and seemingly doesn’t care, leading to his
properties having terribly disappointing endings.
Many Shonen seem to suffer from similar problems.
For instance in Bleach, the Soul Society was a
fantastic early arc. However, it seemed like Tite
Kubo wasn’t sure what should happen afterward…so
they rinsed and repeated with a new kidnapped
ally to rescue and a new assortment of powerful
baddies to fight. Dragon Ball Z kind of does
this, too. And who can forget the ending of
Naruto when we found out *Big Spoiler Warning,
by the way…* it was aliens all along? Granted,
One Piece also has some moon and space
stuff going on, but that’s been well
established for hundreds of chapters instead
of suddenly appearing at the very last minute!
Most shonen also deal with “power creep” -
the problem of running into an impossibly
strong villain, having the heroes
develop a new powerup to defeat them,
and then rinsing and repeating over and
over, until the powers are just absurd and
don’t fit within the established scope of the
narrative. And while One Piece does have cool
powers and power-ups, it avoids the problem of
power creep that we see in many other series.
In an early scene, we’re introduced to
one of the literal strongest characters
in the entire series - Hawkeyes Mihawk,
the greatest swordsman in the world,
one of those Seven Warlords of the Sea
I mentioned earlier. In that encounter,
Luffy’s crewmate Zoro, whose goal is to become
the world’s greatest swordsman faces off against
him. Zoro, who we’ve seen effortlessly take out
opponents left and right before this moment,
is absolutely annihilated by Mihawk. Thanks
to this scene, and some others like it,
we early on get to see the power ceiling
of the world. This way, future power-ups
don’t seem pulled out of nowhere - instead they
seem in line with the properties of the world.
The consistency of One Piece is outstanding.
Even the “bad” arcs - or the least favorites
among the fandom - often surpass the
quality of most other series. Are there
occasional flaws or inconsistencies?
Sure, Oda is surprisingly still human,
after all. But the positives of this
series, especially given its massive length,
outshine the negatives by far. And
this is mainly thanks to chapter 5:
The overall Tone
Another reason to watch One Piece - at least the
final reason we’ll talk about today - is its tone.
And this encapsulates a lot of things. When Matt
Owens, a producer on the upcoming Netflix live
action One Piece series was talking about adapting
the series, he said One Piece does three things:
It makes you laugh, it makes you cry,
and it makes you say “holy shit.”
First and foremost something that really makes
One Piece stand out among its peers is its sense
of humor. Sure, other Shonen often have gags
and bits of humor sprinkled in, but One Piece
really has laughter baked into its core. I mean,
just look at some of these character designs.
And the scenarios they get themselves into can
be just as funny. Luffy, having rubber powers,
is essentially just a stretchy cartoon man.
Sometimes to fight he blows himself up into a
massive balloon. Once, when fighting a character
with food-based powers, he valiantly ate his way
to victory with the voracious appetite
that only a shonen protagonist can have.
Some people criticize One Piece for its wacky and
goofy art style, but the truth is this is one of
its greatest strengths. Not just because it’s
hilarious, but because it makes the emotional
and serious moments hit that much harder.
You’ll just be sitting there enjoying your
goofy pirate manga, when suddenly you are
openly sobbing. I don’t care if you have
a heart of stone. You will cry when you see
the suffering this cute reindeer has endured.
And when you see the ridiculous stakes that
these arcs get to, you’ll be stunned. When an
entire country of people are at stake and the only
possibility of saving them means Luffy defeating
a villain who has already utterly defeated him
multiple times, you’ll be on the edge of your
seat - and even if you know deep down that things
will work on fine because there are still hundreds
of chapters to go…it won’t stop you from jumping
for joy when Luffy finally beats that big bad.
Lots and lots and lots of reasons that you need
to check out One Piece. From the world building,
to the characters, to the story, this is a
must-read piece of media. Experiencing the
story live along with a dedicated fan
community isn’t something you want to
miss out on. And once you get caught up,
you can always come back to the channel
to enjoy some of these theory and character
analysis videos. Or you can start right now,
by watching the best one piece
theory you will ever see, i guess.